Over the past several years, SpaceX has received
a lot of well deserved praise and acclamation
for their strides in lowering rocket launch
cost.
Another organization, however, that isn’t
nearly as celebrated is India’s space organization:
ISRO.
For decades, ISRO has slowly but consistently
been driving down the cost of missions across
the board including orbital missions, lunar
missions, and even martian missions.
So, here’s the story of the space underdog:
ISRO.
ISRO was officially founded on August 15,
1969, but the organization's roots stretch
back decades.
The earliest known roots trace back to Indian
physicist S.K.
Mitra in the 1920s.
Mitra was most famously known for his experiments
relating to ionosphere soundings.
An ionosphere sounding is a telecommunications
technique used to identify the most optimal
radio frequency in a given area.
Scientists use this information to form a
better understanding of the upper atmosphere
and Earth’s near space environment.
Aside from S.K.
Mitra, we also had C.V.
Raman and Meghnad Saha who also completed
a variety of space related experiments throughout
the 1920s and 1930s.
But, the first major leap forward wouldn’t
come till the 1940s when the physical research
laboratory and the tata institute of fundamental
research were founded.
These two organizations were founded by scientists
Vikram Sarabhai and Homi Bhabha respectively.
Each organization leveraged nearby universities
and research laboratories to conduct experiments
relating to cosmic radiation, upper atmospheric
studies, and high altitude tests.
In 1962, Vikram Sarabhai would convince prime
minister Nehru to set up the Indian National
Committee for Space Research.
And soon after, India would begin experimenting
with sounding rockets which eventually led
to the formation of ISRO or the Indian Space
Research Organization in 1969.
Since then, ISRO has developed 5 different
launch vehicles with the first being the Satellite
Launch Vehicle or SLV.
The SLV was a rather small rocket with a payload
capacity of only 40 kilograms.
Despite its relative simplicity, it took ISRO
7 years to develop, and unfortunately the
first launch in 1979 would end up failing
nonetheless.
A faulty valve would end up causing the rocket
to crash into the Bay of Bengal just 317 seconds
after launch.
ISRO would give the SLV another try just a
year later in 1980, and this time, the launch
would be successful.
ISRO would successfully launch the Rohini
RS-1 satellite into orbit which made India
the sixth country to reach orbit.
SLV would go on to be used two more times
with mixed results.
The third launch itself was successful, but
the satellite was launched in too low of an
orbit which would cause the satellite to deorbit
9 days after launch.
The fourth launch would take place in 1983,
and this mission would be a success allowing
ISRO to send an earth observation satellite
into orbit.
Following the success of the SLV, ISRO would
attempt to make a more advanced version of
the SLV called the ASLV.
The ASLV was a five stage solid fuel rocket
that aimed to deliver payloads into geostationary
orbit.
Unfortunately, this rocket would end up being
a massive disappointment.
Throughout its lifetime, the ASLV would complete
4 launches out of which 3 were failures.
The first failure took place in 1987 when
the first stage of the rocket failed to ignite
after launch.
Just one year later, ISRO would try again,
but this time the launcher would end up disintegrating.
The third launch of the ASLV would take place
in 1992, and similar to the SLV failure, the
satellite would be released in too low of
an orbit and it would end up deorbiting.
The fourth and final launch of the ASLV would
take place in 1994, and this launch was actually
a success.
But given the checkered past of the ASLV,
ISRO would decide to discontinue the rocket
and focus their effort on the PSLV or the
Polar Satellite Launch Vehicle.
The PSLV was designed to deliver payloads
into Sun Synchronous orbit and this rocket
is what would really prove the capability
of ISRO.
Ironically, the first flight of the PSLV in
1994 would end up being a failure.
However, PSLV would end up having a streak
of 50 successful launches.
The PSLV is actually still used to this day
and it has even put 342 foreign satellites
from 36 different countries into various orbits.
Up until this year, the PSLV actually held
the record for deploying the most number of
satellites into sun synchronous orbit in a
single launch.
Aside from being an extremely reliable launch
vehicle, the PSLV is also extremely cost efficient.
Each launch is estimated to cost between $18
and $28 million.
We’ll estimate on the higher side and call
it $25 million per launch.
The PSLV is capable of delivering 3800 kg
into low earth orbit meaning that it costs
$6579 per kilogram.
To put that into perspective, NASA’s upcoming
SLS rocket is expected to be able to put 70
metric tons into orbit, but the price tag
per launch is over $2 billion.
This means that the cost per kilogram is $28,572
which is over four times the cost of PSLV.
Now, PSLV isn’t nearly as cost efficient
as the Falcon 9 which only costs $2,193 per
kilogram which is only about a third of the
cost of PSLV.
Nonetheless, the PSLV is way more efficient
than options coming out from NASA today and
the PSLV was designed way back in the 1980s
and 90s.
Anyway, ISRO’s next rocket was the Geosynchronous
Satellite Launch Vehicle or the GSLV.
This is basically like an updated version
of the ASLV and has a payload capacity of
5000 kg.
The GSLV has thus far had 13 launches out
of which 8 were successful, 2 were partial
failures, and 3 were complete failures.
The GSLV is still used today to send larger
payloads into geostationary transfer orbit.
And that brings us into ISRO’s final rocket
which is the GSLV Mark 3.
This rocket was developed in the early 2000s,
and is ISRO’s most powerful rocket capable
of sending 10,000 kg into low earth orbit.
Similar to the PSLV, the GSLV Mark 3 is quite
cost efficient in terms of cost per kilogram.
The GSLV Mark 3 costs $51 million per launch
meaning that it costs $5,100 per kilogram.
So far, the GSLV Mark 3 has only had 4 launches
and all of them have been a success.
It definitely looks like ISRO has significantly
improved their reliability compared to the
early days.
Anyway, moving onto notable ISRO projects
completed with these rockets, we first have
a handful of satellite programs.
The IRS series for instance consists of a
group of satellites in sun synchronous orbit.
These satellites allow India to map and monitor
natural resources such as fresh water.
Another group of satellites managed by ISRO
is the INSAT series.
This group is located in geostationary transfer
orbit and it provides telecommunications and
broadcasting capabilities.
Fun fact, INSAT is the largest domestic communications
system in the Asia-Pacific region.
ISRO also has satellites within their Gagan
satellite navigation system and within IRNSS.
These groups provide navigation, communications,
surveillance, and many more services to ISRO
and India.
ISRO’s satellites are cool and all, but
where it gets really interesting is their
lunar and martian missions.
After China successfully sent humans into
space, India started to focus on trying to
send humans to the moon.
And the first step in this journey was sending
a probe to the moon.
In 2008, ISRO use a modified version of the
PSLV to launch Chandrayaan 1 to the moon,
and the probe became the first probe to prove
the existence of water on the Moon.
According to Chandrayaan 1, the Lunar Poles
hold over 600 billion kilograms of ice.
ISRO wouldn’t attempt another Lunar mission
for quite some time, but the next attempt
would be a massive step up compared to Chandrayaan
1.
Chandrayaan 2 was launched in 2019 using the
GSLV mark 3, and it consisted of a lunar orbiter,
lander, and rover which were all developed
by India themselves.
The goal of the mission was to prove ISRO’s
ability to complete a soft landing on the
Lunar surface.
Unfortunately though, a software glitch would
result in the lander deviating from the planned
path and crashing into the surface of the
moon.
ISRO is planning on trying the soft landing
once again with Chandrayaan 3 which is expected
to take place in 2022.
Moving onto their martian mission, we have
Mangalyaan 1.
In November of 2013, ISRO launched Mangalyaan
1 to Mars, and the spacecraft would successfully
enter Martian orbit in september of 2014.
This made India the first country to enter
Martian orbit on their first attempt.
What’s even more impressive though is that
they were able to complete the entire mission
at a record low cost of $74 million.
To put that in perspective, martian orbital
missions completed by NASA generally cost
hundreds of millions of dollars.
For instance, the Mars Odyssey mission cost
$297 million, the MAVEN mission cost $671
million, and Mars Reconnaissance Orbiter cost
$720 million.
Mangalyaan 1 was literally almost 1/10 of
the cost of the Mars Reconnaissance Orbiter.
Clearly, ISRO has made massive strides when
it comes to reducing the cost of space missions,
but they’re just getting started.
Looking forward, ISRO plans to launch Aditya
L1 to the Sun in 2022, Shukrayaan 1 to Venus
in 2023, and Mangalyaan 2 to Mars in 2024.
They also have a mission to Jupiter planned,
but we don’t have the details of that mission
yet.
Looking forward though, the future of ISRO
is looking especially bright as their budget
continues to be increased year after year.
ISRO’s budget has tripled over just the
last 10 years.
This is in stark contrast to NASA whose budget
peaked 50 years ago.
At the end of the day, ISRO is one of the
most advanced space organizations in the world.
They’re not quite on the level of SpaceX
when it comes to cost efficiency but they’re
magnitudes ahead of other government funded
space programs.
Considering this, it’s just a matter of
time until ISRO places humans in orbit and
eventually on the moon and mars.
Did you guys realize how cost efficient ISRO
was?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you guys hope that NASA
will soon focus on reducing cost themselves.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.